hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the Halloween
edition of five nights at Freddy's 4 now
this is probably the last video that I'm
gonna make on the Halloween edition
mostly because the rest is just the
challenge modes and I'm not insane I may
have spent nine seven hours doing the 20
20 20 20 modes in the past but these
seem obscenely difficult and I don't
know if I would ever be able to beat
them I don't know if I want to dedicate
my brainpower to beating them so this
might be the last one I just want to
finish up night six because this is
finally where the marionette comes into
play or at least that's what I've seen
so far and I'm hoping that I didn't
leave blind mode on because that's going
to be stupid uh it was actually really
interesting seeing the response from
people watching blind mode because
obviously there was nothing to watch
there was really nothing to watch there
you only had listen in that kind of
hello hi
Hey whoa oh my god
already oh geez come on get go man I've
forgotten complete how to play
oh is that all though whoa what did he
get closer
well that's not fair oh god I'm gonna
die
Oh what oh my god
something right here
okay all right then geez um this is bad
oh okay
all right then this is not good okay
there he is that's the boy that's the
big boy there that's Mangal girls girl
very much a girl but definitely a girl
is not going well for me
oh she's in the kitchen good that gives
me some time
oh jeez I really forgot how hard this
was okay good good good good good
still in the kitchen like I don't know
why I didn't emphasize sound as much as
as I had in the past it's really hard to
talk when I'm trying to say things okay
Hawking
so here's define thank god damn okay now
I can actually see things what front
bear oh that's right you're oh oh
hi okay well that that's not I could
have sworn on the sixth night that's
when nightmare Fred or nightmare the
nightmare Freddy Fred Bear thing
thingamabob or thing you know the black
bear that's when it appeared can you
hear me I don't know if you can hear me
I'm sorry okay well then I guess I have
to do something else to get the
marionette to play or I could just play
nightmare mode again cuz now is so much
fun to do playing that for hours and
hours I don't want to have to beat
nightmare mode again I'll give it a few
goes I'll give it a few goes I can
promise damn it
bang nabbit pissin balls get back here
you [ __ ]
face me noogie woogie woogie doggie
woggie gonna bark don't you oogie oogie
boogie woogie gonna shut the hell up
oh boy honey good
was that breathing oh that wasn't
breathing Willie crap I'm dead god damn
it [ __ ] oh I thought I heard Britt it's
so hard with mangle there god damn it
ah there's gonna be a [ __ ] why do I
have to beat nightmare mode again I
don't want to beat nightmare mode again
I don't want to
aah it's such a [ __ ] let's go all
nightmare mode let's do it let's go
balls-out on this but I'm not doing
nightmare nightmare all nightmare mode
I'm gonna do six night
now v 9 6 9 6 night all nightmare mode
nightmare all nightmare mode I'm doing
it I'm doing all I'm doing nightmare all
nightmare mode here we go come on just
go straight up nightmare all nightmare
mode nightmare all nightmare have a
double-decker nightmare going on here
nightmare holding her I'm her only Marik
Emeril dinner Oh
I don't know what to do
I don't know what to do boo oh holy
balls oh my god f that F that F this
[ __ ] [ __ ] make up your goddamn
[ __ ] come on damn it come on
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] oh no no oh
god oh god oh god [ __ ] me oh I heard
that I heard noises I heard noises Dan I
expect are you doing water balloon
dammit
at least now I'm dancing with marionette
like I wanted to do all night long baby
all night long all night long all night
long oh my god like one
he's inside isn't he
I'm [ __ ] yeah he's he's he's out this
is hard this is very difficult I think I
might actually be able to do it maybe
who knows I don't know no I'm not gonna
have fun with Balloon Boy before I do
this no I refer
I review every few No
whoa-oh-oh
how did I survive that I don't know
titties titties
he moved to the left he moved to the
left he did I heard it it happened
damn it it happened I was there I was
right on top of the blue-eyed I was
doing the thing why am i trying this why
am i trying this why am i trying this
I want that fifth star
that is nearly impossible there's that
is nearly impossible oh ok so as a
little trainer for me so that I can tell
what he's doing I'm gonna turn on the
house map because I want to know like
definitively what the laughs mean is
there a consistent pattern to the laughs
is there something I can do to predict
against the laughs is there something I
can do to protect myself when the laughs
come so I want to know I want to know
okay so those beginning footsteps he's
not even fair he's just being a douche
nozzle like is like is there one laughs
that says one thing is there another
laughs that says another like okay he's
just appeared oh oh he's coming oh he's
off oh he's up coming so I just shut
this door and he's gone whoa jeez um Dan
that guy moves quick close it thank you
Oh switching doing the old chimichanga
there we go but I'm listening for the
laughs the laughs is what I really want
jam son so it only takes like a half a
second of not movement okay he just he
just laughed and he didn't go anywhere
he just laughed
that was a short that was the short
laugh though that was oh that was the
same laugh that was the same short laugh
that was the same damn short laugh this
[ __ ]
this douchebag okay so the walk cycles
are very easy to predict he always moves
like every two seconds it seems like it
and if he doesn't move back immediately
from switching sides he's coming down
that side so that's important to note
yeah okay so that's educational buddy he
decided not to laugh in this one because
he's a prick okay I had fast night on
there so obviously that was very cheney
but i could have done the door like it
was like the laugh the laugh was exactly
the same it was exactly the damn same
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna turn off fast
nights I'm gonna do it again and this
time he better laugh more so I can
understand his laugh maybe like a long
time ago I had like thought that the
first laughs whatever laugh it was was
not real like that was a fakey fake
laugh he wasn't really laughing he
wasn't doing anything he wasn't trying
to be anything he was just doing there
was another laugh it doesn't make any
sense it doesn't make any sense
I think it's
there I'm wondering if the are laughs
like auditory as well like if I had
better headphones could I tell the
position of the laugh let me try to
listen for that next time
that was a serious laugh see the problem
is when he laughs and he's coming down
the hallway like you yeah kind of [ __ ]
out of luck there because he's silent
when he comes down the hallway if he
made like foots was I slow he wasn't
even at the door this is baloney
this is malarkey this is asinine this is
impossible there is no way there's no
way the laughs don't make any sense you
laugh and then move along why it would
be impossible it would be totally
impossible before I in this episode I'm
gonna see what the other sheets are not
cheats but challenges I'm gonna see what
they are because I imagine I know what
mad Fred emote is we already know what
blind mode is insta foxy I'm pretty sure
that means foxy comes with right in the
beginning but he would do that anyway so
what is there to gain
oh I hear oh my god three already well
we know what mad Freddie is jeez um oh
boy they're bolts coming down Oh God
Jake is at the door chica thought the
door chicas out the door Oh God
Oh Freddie Oh Freddie Freddie Freddie
Freddie Freddie Freddie ah oh god I was
very worried can we can we go can we go
back now
Oh oh no oh no oh no oh no what do i do
what do i do what do i do oh good oh
okay oh that makes wait is that like a
strategy could I close the door twice I
guess I could technically Oh interesting
oh geez oh my god I did not expect you
to actually come out of there hooky
alright then
so that's mad Freddie seems like mad
Freddie you could handle that that just
needs a little more Freddie action so
long as you play attention to the noises
challenge inste foxy I can only imagine
I can only imagine I really wonder if
Scott has ever beaten these modes I
doubt it
I doubt it very much yep though this is
obvious barf barf barf barf I'm a dog
bark bark bark bark bark bark bark
look at me I'm mangle barf barf barf
barf barf or boy oh boy oh boy oh god he
did not like that
he didn't like that at all oh boy
alright then now we know that what foxy
will tolerate not that the five guys
Freddy's to strategy of strobing him
with the light doesn't seem to work hmm
alright so that is all I'm going to do
for the Halloween edition of five nights
at Freddy's I do not think I will ever
be able to beat those I do not think I'm
up to the task i relinquish my crown to
the next Yonder character who doth beat
these dip impossible modes I feel as
though my time reigning as king of five
nights at Freddy's
Fagin is gonna go on forever I'm always
gonna be the king of ayodhya Freddie's
if anyone wants to take my crown love to
covet baby with a fish boy
no one's gonna change him sorry about
that but I still consider myself the
king of five nights at freddys I will
never give up my crown no matter how bad
I am at everything I do in life so thank
you everybody so much for watching until
the inevitable next five nights at
Freddy's adventure and heck maybe I'll
practice nightmare and all nightmare
mode in my free time and maybe all try
to beat it so thank you again everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
you know I feel a deeper connection